this compendium was funded by State
Department funds through the Asia
Pacific Partnership on claim development
and climate to look at what is the best
and the brightest with the United States
and share those perspectives with or
other countries in the Asia Pacific
Partnership principally India and China
and coincidentally that is what we're
going to be focusing on this final panel
India and China so we're staying true to
form here and but what we're going to do
is talk about a little bit about what
are we what are the experts on the
panel's seeing at the state and local
level of sub-national level rather in
China and India and reflect a little bit
on what they've heard earlier today in
terms of the u.s. experiences and what
is the relevancy of the u.s. experiences
to what we're finding overseas so we
will start with India portion we have
two individuals representing the India
perspective one will be joining us very
quickly telephonically but we'll start
with one mesh bra me and for those of
you who are here earlier in the morning
when mesh is is indeed a Yale a world
fellow and and he Tim Jarvis have our
co-creators of the new climate civics
Institute and we had a hour and a half
session this morning which was very
informative and they're doing some great
work first in India then moving on to
Australia but but in mesh is much more
than simply a World fellow at Yale
although as prestigious as that is would
mesh presently serves as a senior vice
president for corporate sustainability
for HSBC in India at dabangg Kia
successfully launched a number of
businesses aligned corporate
sustainability initiatives including
significant bottom of the pyramid work
and microfinance financial literacy
environment sustainability climate
change and stakeholder engagement themes
all of which were are embedded in in the
climate civics Institute so English
please share your insights and
perspectives from India sorry thank
goodness for that
welcome good afternoon everybody we
heard issues today which all of us have
been grappling with historically as well
as currently between nations within
countries and some of the examples of
how local action really propels and
catalyzes change I'm going to speak for
my assigned five minutes on India and
dramatic confusion we are facing in
terms of renewable energy and how
collaboration between countries between
energy firms between energy service
companies utilities can actually create
a positive market in the Indian context
so let me quickly outline what is the
conclusion India obviously accepted to
voluntary cutting carbon emissions basis
the common and differentiated response
in platform and is currently voluntarily
committed to cut emissions by
twenty-five percent by 2025 over two
thousand five levels now while it's nice
to say so it's important to review the
situation locally and I'm quite happy to
state that within the country the Prime
Minister's Office in India has issued
almost year and a half of the national
action plan on climate change which is
the policy framework document which is
guiding the matter in which India would
be able to achieve a low-carbon
inclusive and that's the key word if you
don't use the word inclusive and don't
practice it governments will fall
because nobody else understands climate
change and sixty percent of the people
who vote for various politicians would
not vote for them if issues other than
climate change are in disgust so it's
interesting situation where and we have
the national action plan on climate
change which outlines eight missions to
do with various a low-carbon pathways to
do with solar to do with your thermal
with tidal energy knowledge sharing
adaptation for vulnerable communities so
on and so forth yet the attraction
doesn't seem to be developing in terms
of critical market for renewable energy
and I think the problem here is the fact
that fifty percent of the country still
does not have access to electricity
most of our results and electricity
generation is based on coal now the big
confusion and the big question is can we
in the near future one years two years
three shift the tipping point if at all
there is one in such a way that everyone
gets access to Alexei basis renewable
energy and I think that's a problem with
you u.s. is facing we've talked about a
cold States today and how to get around
that and that's where I see a spoofer
collaboration in terms of small projects
in distributed energy projects which use
biomass of the basis of small production
solar all of these will have their role
to play the Bureau of energy efficiency
is another organ action in the country
which is pushing the clean energy agenda
at a household level as well and we have
now appliances with what we call a five
star energy rating which is there more
efficient than the rest of the
appliances but I see very few of them on
Michelle's which is if i go to buy air
conditioner I me see one brand which
talks about our energy rating but the
advertising and marketing bother
branches so very glamorous that you
gravitate towards those and forget a
five star rating so where is the entire
a slew of manufacturers coming up and
accepting these ratings by the Bureau of
energy efficiency there is talk about
energy credits but I think while once
you why is these credits have been
approved by the government or immunity
credits I'm not sure how long will it
take to put into practice having said
all of this there is coo in terms of
small projects which today are showing
some futuristic traction in terms of how
you manage energy needs I know of
projects which we are not trying to
support through which is bc which use
rice husk to generate local electricity
I off projects when people have taken
plantations and planted biodiesel
yielding species to create a betrayal
economy of sorts there are various
aspects to do with how you provide
energy to the bottom of pyramid using
renewable technologies solar being one
of them LED lighting being one of them
and all of this there is a distinct
movement to use microfinance as a root
and then I think which is where the
scope really lies because if you are
able to take the
current population of the country and
put them into the energy matrix and try
and secure some form of clean energy for
them that's when you will have this
grassroots movement growing so I think
while nationally there is confusion we
still seem to be driven toward school
locally this tiny initiatives will
indeed make a difference you know we
heard earlier Valerie from Valerie Brown
that state and local officials are very
agile what we're going to be agile right
now and we're going to shift for me
shift from India over to China hopefully
to come back to India but our first
speaker on China is nancy Hamas back who
was the first chinese-american to serve
as executive director of the Yale china
association the yale china association
is a private nonprofit organization
located here on the yale campus has
worked to build us chatting relations on
the grassroots level since nineteen oh
one through programs in education health
public service and the yards as mosbach
spent several years was Goldman Sachs in
Hong Kong in New York where she worked
in the investment banking division
executive office and global markets
Institute miss mosbach also spent
several years at the Council on Foreign
Relations as managing director of
corporate programs the CFR hitachi
international affairs fellow based in
japan and a research associate in china
miss mosbach sits on the national board
of the association of asian american
Yale alumni she is the degree from
occidental college and an mba from yale
school of management Nancy well in that
background you notice there was nothing
specifically on climate change or
environmental policies so i would i
would like to share thoughts on this
morning and it's really an honor to be
here next to people i could mention
barber Fenimore and Richard Kaufman
people I've read their writings on on
this topic but what I'd like to sort of
share from sort of the ground up level
is what I'm seeing on from our
relationships and partnerships on the
ground in China and I think it's in
reaction to some of the discussion
that's been happening throughout the day
I think it might be very relevant Yale
China as Griffin has a suggestion and
we've shared it has been in China for
over 100 years we have office in
changsha hunan which I'm not sure how
many of you have been to Changsha but
it's inland and also in Hong Kong and
we've been in tongues out for 100 years
that gives an institution that is based
in the u.s. a lot of leverage and what
we've noticed on many levels is as an
NGO operating in China there are certain
limitations and in fact on the NGO level
I think Barbara price yet a lot more on
that level but from our perspective is
we often leverage our partners in many
ways to get things done and actually
right now there is no official language
in China that is comparable to NGOs as
we understand them from the US
perspective I lay that all out as a
preface because I think that's critical
information to absorb and understand as
we think about what's happening in
environmental policy space and climate
change space on the ground in China and
then I'd like to suggest that there is
no infrastructure there is no
infrastructure in China from my
perspective to really deal with a lot of
the issues and hopes and dreams that we
have in this space in the US and as we
see from other parts of the world and
infrastructure is in terms of my former
mentor and supervisor and personal and
professional friend Elizabeth economy
who is one of the foremost leaders in
this space you know she expresses three
main challenges with China one rule of
law to transparency and three official
accountability those are not foreign
concepts I think to us when we think
about China but what I'd like to suggest
from a very late lay viewpoint is that
it's not trendy right now there is
nothing trendy about it and there are no
leaders in the space and when we talk
about China we're often talking about
this Center Beijing we're not talking
about even the provincial level but most
of all we're not talking on the
corporate level or on the ground from a
representative individual one-on-one
level there is no leadership in this
space and and as many of us recognize in
China there are basically three main
players there SOS state-owned
enterprises there are two foreign
enterprises multinational corporations
that have very little power in a space
where they are profiting in a way that
can be viewed as detrimental to the
environment so very little leverage
point there and
most recently recognized group are the
domestic private entrepreneurs these I
will suggest are the leaders in this
space for us to really keep our eyes on
and I'd suggest that an example of this
from what we've seen and this is a
company that's based in changsha hunan
broad you antha has anyone heard abroad
before that's wonderful that you haven't
today is a day you're going to learn
about them broad is a private end
company its main it has three business
lines one is non electric air
conditioning air cooling systems the
second is air purifiers and the third is
sustainable buildings there are private
company based in changsha they have an
emphasis like campus in tanks odd I've
been had the privilege of staying
overnight there and benefiting from all
there are different products there air
purifiers prefabricated buildings a lot
of these different types of products
that they sell about worth about 300
million dollars i'd suspect so a very a
leader in this space chairman Zhang yeah
the head of the company is a leader in
this space in every respect on the China
front he's a leader not only because
he's creating products that actually
contribute and make the world cleaner
and better but to he's trying to be a
global citizen and he's doing that
against the tide against tight in China
for a number of reasons he's very proud
of the taxes he pasted the government so
he gets a lot of respect from Beijing to
he refuses any bribes at all and this is
part of his mantra and and three he's
very dogmatic about sharing how one
should be a global citizen and he's
printed these little books that
basically say you should have one child
not because the government tells you to
but because one child will save 250
trees so he's done that sort of analysis
and he's really been a leader in that
space he's also been awarded the globe
he's a global partner for the world expo
in China and because of all this work in
the leadership space he's the exclusive
supplier of the central air conditioning
the ventilation and air purification
products for the shanghai expo i
recommend that when you all go there
between may and october this year that
you will recognize and look out for
broad and really see that leadership i'm
excited about what china can do but only
as much as we can see corporate leaders
private entrepreneurs take the
otherwise the impact will be so far we
will all be dead in variation by the
time we see that sort of uptick so in
that sense I think that we Chinese are
very practical in the sense there is no
infrastructure there's no cool moms
there aren't any cool moms out there in
China right now and we really need to
encourage that sort of leadership from
many different levels but I think the
most successful route is definitely on
the ground from the corporate
perspective and domestic enterprises and
the only final point as many of you may
be familiar if you follow China Fred who
is the chief economist at Goldman Sachs
he's also a hunan native and he said if
it can happen in Hunan which is what
brought his base it can happen anywhere
in China Beijing Shanghai and Guangzhou
do not represent China thank you very
much Nancy a very nice nice touch a nice
perspective we are told that are linked
with India is not going to work so we'll
continue on with rust of the China
presentation Ramesh you are the sole in
being representative here the burden is
on you after you know what a burn you
can fill nicely our next speaker is
Barbara Finnemore who is the founder and
director of the China program at the
natural natural resources defense
council and RDC one of the world's most
effective environmental organizations
NRDC was the first international
environmental group to establish a clean
energy program in China as Fenimore now
leads NRDC's 30-member china teamwork
working out of our Beijing and us
offices on climate change energy
efficiency renewable energy responsible
sourcing sustainable cities
environmental governance I personally
had to add a met Barbara and solver team
in Beijing several years ago a
delightful lunch and I learned to learn
so much about the workings in China NRDC
works with China to build capacity and
develop innovative laws policies
technologies and market mechanisms to
accelerate its transition to a clean
low-carbon economy
and Mayor Nichols you have a fellow
Harvard grad here she's Barbara has a
degree from Harvard Law School if that's
okay Barbara it's all yours this doesn't
seem to turn on no it's just for it's a
gimmick gimmick it's a prize yeah
official help when did you have to speak
oh oh I get it okay thank you Griff and
it's a pleasure and a delight for me to
be here with all of you today to talk
about sub-national efforts in China
because that's been a fascination of
mine for nearly 20 years since my first
experience in China was to work with
about 70 different government agencies
to develop China's blueprint for
sustainable development for the 21st
century which was very very advanced it
was the first one prepared throughout
the world after the rio conference but
China recognized even then that it was
going to depend upon the provinces to
carry it out and there was a lot of
interest at that time even at the local
level in the cities in helping to carry
out the ambitious targets at that time
this is 20 years ago in their
sub-national provincial and local plans
when i first started for NRDC started
our energy sea program about 15 years we
quickly learned that it was we were
going to get nowhere at the central
government level in promoting energy
efficiency at that point all they cared
about was economic development and
actually electrification of the country
because so much of the country just
didn't have access so that was their
main focus and we would talk about
energy efficiency and system benefit
charge and things like that got
absolutely nowhere so we learned very
quickly the only way we were going to
make a difference is to go to find a
good profits and try to test out these
policies that we saw working so well in
the United States and that's actually
been our focus all these years in
Chinese to take best practices from in
the u.s. actually efficiency renewables
it has been
primarily the state level and the city
level of things that we heard about
earlier today take those best practices
bring them to China and help them figure
out where what parts of it might make
sense how to adapt it for use in China's
condition and so we moved to John Hsu
province which interestingly enough is a
sister province from with California and
has always seen itself as the California
of China it shares a lot of
characteristics it's very well developed
economically and and they wanted to
emulate our work there so but but before
I go further I do have to say that
interplay is different in China that it
is in the u.s. because it's a unitary
government so all of the provinces have
every agency of the provincial level is
you know tied at least through a dotted
line weight to the central government
agency there like many central
governments in every province and the
officials of the provincial governors
for example up report to the central
government and that's a very important
factor I'll talk about in a minute but
it also I mean it has its advantages and
disadvantages well one disadvantage is
that in many cases provinces do not have
the kind of freedom and ability to to
experiment with new policies that they
do in this country they have to seek
approval in certain ways in it for
certain things so it hampers their
ability for the most primitive the most
active provinces to develop those kind
of advanced policies and mechanisms that
we've been trying to promote on the
other hand when they do figure out a way
to get around these constraints and come
up with pilots that work it's much
easier for them to be disseminated to
the national level and become national
policy this so that's been our that's
been our strategy and it's work it's
worked in jang-soo particularly for
energy efficiency we've got we developed
the first energy efficiency potential
stud
in China in John Hsu showed enormous
potential much bigger than you're going
to find anywhere in the US Jackson
couldn't believe the numbers but when
they looked him over it spent a year
reviewing them they said goodness we
want to do something we want to capture
this energy efficiency potential they
found a way to use revenues from their
electricity system and developed the
first provincial level demand-side
management program and so that
eventually was cited by the premier of
China ads model for the rest of China
and the central government is about to
develop and issue national regulations
that are going to allow utilities in
every province to recover the costs of
helping their customers save energy so
this is a major breakthrough I'm
delighted about and now we're in the
process of working with four other major
provinces and cities who want to do the
same thing and hebei is another example
they they had their neighbor the actual
first ones to develop a system benefit
charge for dsm demand-side management in
their province that only provides a
certain amount of funding for energy
efficiency so now they're developing
exploring new financing mechanisms for
energy efficiency one is called the
super esco that will bring together a
lot the kind of active general
contractor for a lot of specific ESCOs
in in meeting customers needs for
retrofits and industrial building
sectors another is a public-private
partnerships for for financing of energy
efficiency so we're working very closely
with them I want to say however that
just like in the u.s. not every province
is like Jung soo some are very
progressive and others lag behind so
here's another benefit I think of the
way that Chinese political system is set
up because now the government has caught
on to the value of energy efficiency and
climate protection it has set national
targets I'm sure you've all heard about
one is this twenty percent reduction in
energy intensity between twenty two
thousand five or twenty ten well how do
they meet that or how are they trying to
meet it because they haven't yet and
that
they've allocated the target to every
province and this is the key point they
have adjusted the job performance rating
system of every provincial governor and
the head of all the top 1000 energy
using enterprises to reflect how well
they have achieved their portion of the
National target I just wonder what the
state officials in this country would
feel if they were also rated by the
President on how well they are achieving
the national goals such as they are or
whether we come up with them but that is
the reality in China and I have never
seen any mechanism be so successful then
this one in gathering the attention of
these provincial officials there's still
a ways away they have to lea under this
year to meet it but I think between you
know all the incentive policies that try
to set up which they're taking advantage
of and this very important job
performance rating system they're going
to come as close as they can to meet
this ambitious target on renewable
energy a lot of the action has been at
the national level actually top-down a
renewable energy law recalled in Sun
golden roof major incentive programs
feed-in tariffs for wind and targets for
wind for solar for biomass by 2020 very
ambitious ones they keep having to
revised upwards and major investment
last year China for the first time was
the number one investor in clean energy
in the world its investments were about
double those of the US and even though
installed wind capacity in China is
still behind the u.s. they're growing so
fast they're probably going to catch up
this year or next however there's still
room I see for action on the local level
in this case in particular on the city
level particularly in things well
provinces are vying for these major wind
and solar projects there's a city in
inner mongolia ordos which is really the
factory for just about every kind of
noble energy development going on in the
world you know and I spoke last week to
a fellow Gary jerks who was the head of
BP China for about 20 25 years he said
you want to know the future of renewable
energy in the world go to ordos one of
the things they're doing is building the
world's largest solar power plant there
to gigawatts it's going to you know
proof be bigger than the island of
Manhattan when it's fully completed and
that happens to be a project by a US
company I must give it a flood their
first solar one that contract cuz it has
the best technology however solar
feed-in tariff there still is no
national one I think China's a little
bit nervous about that but John Hsu has
instituted the first solar energy
feed-in tariff to try to level the
playing field with is still very cheap
cost of coal-fired power plants so
that's it and I think the biggest action
on their noble side is solar water
heaters China leads the world in this
and has two thirds of the world market
and what we're seeing now is cities
vying to be called Chinese solar city
there's a whole bunch of them and they
have every kind of incentives from
financial incentives to actually
regulations requiring government
buildings to install the solar thermal
or even you know integrated building
systems but the biggest kick that I got
was a couple of weeks ago went to this
town called dojo about two hours on high
speed train of which we don't even have
to start talking about him and Iran
China to two hours of by train from
Beijing it's an entire solar city it's
built by a company a company that is the
largest solar thermal manufacturer in
the world and they wanted to promote
their projects so they built a whole
city just buildings with these solar
thermal products and meant by the way
every other type of solar a technology
that's in existence today to demonstrate
it so that kind of leadership is I agree
is extremely important
seeing it in china so i would say in
addition to the provincial level to the
city level we're seeing it at the
corporate level especially in renewable
energy so i'm pretty excited about this
initiative look forward to working with
you thank you very much barroom now our
final speaker today so it's a Richard
you can serve as the exclamation point
on a long line of good speakers Richard
Kaufman is the chief executive officer
of good energies one of the largest
independent investors in renewable
energy previously Richard was a managing
director of Goldman Sachs and he worked
in numerous leadership positions with
Morgan Stanley Richard also has been a
lecture in finance and financial
accounting at the Yale School of
Management and the Teaching Fellow and
foreign policy at Yale College Richard
is on the board of okay that's cool yeah
I guess we want to go home tonight okay
Richard tell us about the renewable
energy investment okay so when I talk
about solar in China we are major
investor in one of the Chinese solar
manufacturers so we do a lot of other
things other than China but since this
panels on China that's what I'm going to
talk about and so it's a sort of
interesting contrast since we're we've
been talking about things in the United
States and now talking about about China
I'd say that neither place has got
things quite right in terms of
development of of markets and
manufacturing so let's talk about China
first china has some very substantial
assets and so when we talk about China
and solar really talking about Chinese
manufacturing for export so that the
number of it about investment this is
there have been substantial investments
made no question about that but these
are
vestments at least for the moment
primarily dedicated for export what what
we've seen is it's certainly amply
supported by by local local governments
really down to the city level so the
company that I know the mayor's and the
Vice mayors of the of the of the company
into the city and where the company is
located because they're very concerned
about employment they will do anything
that they can to help out so when this
company needs a new plant we can get it
approved in a week and so you can
imagine in comparison to the United
States how difficult it is to get local
that kind of local support local banks
now we know what's going on with the
financial sector United States the solar
industry is below investment grade so
the Chinese manufacturers are amply
being provided with ample liquidity from
from local banks and that's a huge asset
and increasingly what we're seeing is
finance being made available for
financing of projects again
international projects of the
manufacturers are for export and that's
a huge huge benefit because it's very
hard to get project financing for solar
projects anywhere in the world that debt
financing so the other assets that that
China has I guess what we talked about a
broadly is is you know they're very few
nimby issues so I sort of touched on
that but even see that on some on the
domestic projects to relate to two
transmissions we talked about feed-in
tariffs you know we don't have feed-in
tariffs in the United States we do have
feed-in tariffs in in in Europe that's
made a huge benefit to the development
of renewable energy deployment generally
and so that's a real positive the fact
that we see that now in China but we
need to recognize that in solar this is
a really tiny tiny tiny part of the
market it's really being used i think is
a kind of backup to support the domestic
to support the manufacturing because
it's really a manufacturing for export
so this this feedin feed in tariffs for
the domestic market is really to support
the manufacturers because they're still
over supply and this actually the
program i think is is really being used
this domestic solar program is really
being used to help the manufacturers get
rid of second and third quality of
production so there's not there's not
much not much margin the prices are low
but it's a way of helping the
economist's would get note the idea that
this helps contribution to to overhead
so you know kind of talked about the
sort of advantages what are the issues
that I see one issue that I see is that
Nancy talked about entrepreneurs on the
manufacturing side we have if you
forgive the pun you know let a thousand
flowers blossom that's what's happening
with with manufacturer with
entrepreneurs these are entrepreneurs
and solar that that want to be in
manufacturing in China is a place for
manufacturing so you have it's not very
hard to get into the solar manufacturing
business the equipment is is widely
available so if you have some capital
you can get into the business and so
that certainly happened and so there are
I don't even know the number of
manufacturers but there are lots of them
trying to get into the solar solar
module manufacturing business and so I
think that the problem with that I think
it's probably good for consumers because
it means the prices have continued to
come down but it's a real problem in
terms of creating profitability for the
industry so I think when I look at it
globally you know I it's not really good
for the solar industry
because if you can't generate
appropriate returns on capital you know
you're not going to you know I don't
need to finish the sentence so that
there's a problem in at some point it's
going to come to tears and one of the
problems with this patchwork between the
national and provincial and state
authorities is that there's nobody
there's no encouragement too much
encouragement to to allow for industry
consolidation and so when you have a
bunch of entrepreneurs that all think
that they're you know really important
than many of them have other businesses
that they can continue to sub to
subsidize this this that they're their
solar business you know it really
creates a lot of cultural problems
towards consolidation no entrepreneur is
going to blink and sell to somebody
else's on somebody to sell sell it
somebody else or work for somebody else
as you can imagine so that's a problem
another problem is that what we've seen
elsewhere in the world is you know we
talk about manufacturing but really if
you want to have renewable energy you
need to be deployed right it's not just
about may affect it needs to be deployed
somewhere so we talk about solar you
talking about building solar parks well
what we've seen elsewhere in the world
is yes utilities are able to do that but
where it works particularly well in the
world is when you have entrepreneurs
that are going around developing
projects because you know if you want it
in local places and benefit of solar is
it's a distributed solution you know
it's works best when you can go find
places where you can secure development
rights and work with local communities
and so we don't that that infrastructure
really doesn't yet exist in in in China
it doesn't exist because we don't really
have enough of a feed-in tariff and we
don't there's no project finance / say
that exists in China that capability
doesn't really exist and so that is a
real problem it's inhibiting the
development of entrepreneurs not we
don't need more entrepreneurs and China
making things making more production we
march Werner's deploying it in the field
and so
the other point I'd make in terms of
Finance is the short term finance is is
a is a real problem I talked about short
term finance that the local banks are
providing short-term financing if you're
in the manufacturing business and you
have relatively long dated assets
finance 101 is you don't finance you
know kind of long dated assets with
short-term debt and that's what goes on
now in China and that is a problem
because if there's a problem in the
financial sector in China and those
loans get those short term short term
loans are renewed the industry that
those those companies will go bankrupt
so there's there's there is a there's a
mismatch and funding so maybe this last
point here I mean this I said at the
beginning that we don't have the United
States and China don't have things quite
right so in the United States oh I'm
sorry one other thing about project
finance because the the the Bennett it's
about innovation because the the the one
of the things that is good about having
a matte critical mass of manufacturing
is that when you have a critical mass
manufacturing and scale that's when
you're going to get innovation and
that's one of things we haven't figured
out quite right in the United States
there's a there's a small but important
little wrinkle when I talk about project
finance that's relevant for innovation
and that is that the way things work is
if you can get project financing say in
Europe or in the United States you can
there's a little bucket that's permitted
for innovative technology for for
another for technology that's not
standard technology and that's the way
that you can test technology so it
events new technology so it eventually
can get project finance and one of the
challenging challenges and renewable
energy is what is bankable what you can
get project finance for and the only way
you can get project financing for
something is after you spin in the field
for a long time so if you hope to get
innovation you have to have project
financing and a lot for this bucket for
for this new technology so just just
just in conclusion I think I think in
the United States we've done a poor job
of creating
critical mass in manufacturing because
we just have less of a focus in
manufacturing of Fortune United States
so China's done a good job in being able
to establish a critical mass
manufacturing it's for export of course
the United States it should have been
for domestic market but that's really
the problem the United States is we
haven't developed a domestic market for
solar of any of any consequence we've
done a really good job of the United
States with project finance we know
really well we have a lot of capability
of project finance China doesn't have
that China's we have a weak banking
sector in terms of lending China we've
talked about it we have obviously nimby
issues the United States China doesn't
we don't have feed-in tariffs in the
United States China China does we use
tax tax benefits and frankly then this
will be my final point you know there's
both countries in it in their own way
need to provide a capital market
solution for long-term financing of
projects so in China there's no domestic
bond market of any consequence and
that's something that's really really
important to develop for China not just
generally and so and so one way to
develop that domestic bond market might
be to use the bond market to develop
funding for long-term long-term project
finance for for renewable projects we
don't have such a we do have a very good
debt mark of the United States but we
don't actually every project though in
the United States is bespoke we don't
have a general standards for for capital
a capital market solution for project
financing so ironically for different
reasons both countries this is a
frontier that both countries could try
to work on and may be solved
well thank you very much Richard I
particularly like the comparisons and
contrasts of China in the US with what
who's doing what perhaps better or not
as well as the other very very
insightful perspectives we have a few
minutes for questions for this
distinguished panel and then we'll wrap
up the day's proceedings questions from
the back my name is she not I'm a first
year of master of environmental
management student at the School of
Forestry and Mike to mr. Loomis how
recently I've been reading about India's
plans to develop 20 gigawatts power from
solar alone and hearing Bob think about
you know China's progress already and
considering the fact that India needs to
spend at least 20 billion dollars to
power up to you know by 2022 I guess so
do you see what kind of prospects do you
see here and you see a lot of people
coming forth with project plans and a
good question in fact most of the
answers were in Richards fantastic
presentation on finance as to what
plagues the financial markets and their
propensity to fund a renewal energy
including solar when I'm trying to work
with US commercial service back home in
India and trying to get the US
manufacturers access to financial
institutions in trying to figure out
whether a route is possible but I think
typically what is happening is it's fine
if you are a solar manufacturing entity
because you have a history of a balance
sheet but if you are a deployment entity
you don't have either so the appetite
for bankers to be able to evaluate
something which is new is not that are
you a quick example through HSBC we
purposefully signed a mission-driven MOU
a member of understanding with the
Bureau of energy efficiency lo behold to
do what to train our creatorís
management people in how to assess
renewable energy projects in how to
figure out a way to if
learn what is a esco or what is the
super esco how to get into performance
contracting and future cash flow
projections basis which a national model
could be created now so this is work in
progress there is lots to be done and
you can only do it by building capacity
the sector of course needless to say the
sector's right now even in the country
the financial sector it's just about
getting over the crisis and it's still
actually mentally chasing money which is
out there in the market it's you're
doing something new so I think these are
the various scenarios the government is
doing all that it can but interestingly
enough even the subsidies being offered
I mean I have been speaking to the
Ministry of renewable energy in India
their subsidy is there I mean but the
point is you have to blend that one
percent interest rate if your cost of
funds are nine percent or eight percent
you can't lend it one person so now what
do you do where do you really create the
incentivization for the banks and in
today's situation you can't really even
keep a part of money inside a bank
singulation doesn't matter i'll put this
at one person because there are somebody
else the other other place in the market
to other customers who may want to take
something as from you at ten eleven
fourteen percent so you can't take that
differential loss at least in this
turbulent state but the government is
doing all it can in terms of giving
power purchase agreements to you know
entities are willing to set up solar
power including promising for example in
state of rajasthan grid connectivity so
i had to take the solar power to the
last mile these are experiments as of
now it will be only time which will tell
us whether this they would really bear
some fruits but the intention is that i
don't see the market developing
immediately i will give it at least
three to five years thanks your honor
any other questions okay thank you all
for being here my name is Wes Morgan I'm
a second year student at the School of
Management my question is mostly for mr.
Kaufman but to some extent to all of you
you Branagh brought up the issue of
there's kind of different areas within
the entire system there's the project
finance there's entrepreneurs we're
doing production but also those are
actually deploying there's several
different pieces of this how how do you
see kind of the project management the
Entrepreneurship of rolling things out
beyond just the financing and beyond
just the manufacturer but how do you see
that coming down the pipeline from
students such as ourselves in the School
of Management both the United States and
abroad I'll take part of it and i
certainly will turn it over to others i
mean i think that the there's true i
mean i'm sure on campus we know there's
tremendous interest in in renewables
right so so I I have lots of a belief
and and and I don't think that there's a
constraining factor that can turns of
binding constraints I don't think there
are binding constraints in terms of
entrepreneurial activity that's not at
all the problem i see i see that the the
problem we have for example the united
states is that we we don't have the
market signals or the regulatory or
regulations right so the consequence of
that is that we have lots of
entrepreneurs that are trying to set
things up but then they can't get very
far and so we've got my favorite thing
is kind of when i talk about innovation
is that we have the innovation
deployment horse and cart backwards
because in the united states we think
that there's a problem the reason we do
have more renewable energy united states
is because we got a technology problem
well i don't think we have a technology
problem we don't have an entrepreneurial
problem not at all i think we have some
we have we have in inhibitions to
deployment to market development because
of bad market signals and because of bad
regulation and so if we can start and we
have an example in Western Europe where
because of feed-in tariffs that I do it
before and and markets developed and
through the development of market and
scale then cost began to decline and
then you had the ability to get more and
more innovation that resulted from
having established a market so that's
the problem i see in the united states
and you know and i think to a degree i'm
not expert in china as much as others on
the panel I but you get if you get it
you certainly get a flavor that there
that the problem is not entrepreneurial
capability in China either we know that
there's some fantastic entrepreneurs in
China but if you don't get some of this
what sounds very prosaic but if you
don't get some of the market structures
right you're just going to block the
entrepreneurial activity or wind up
having entrepreneurs wind up doing
things or staying in areas where they're
going to wind up actually not being that
successful and we're seeing that I think
in in the entrepreneurs for example in
the solar sector they're killing
themselves trying to compete in solar
manufacturing when there might be other
areas where they could could be more
profitable I think you perhaps we're
focusing on project management is that
what you're working on it and I would
just say agree with you completely on
entrepreneurial side but on the project
management side I would say there's
always room for people with expertise in
project management I think that is an
area where China is going to welcome the
kind of Western techniques and expertise
that will help them do a better job in
the project manager so so to answer with
the question you didn't ask yes there's
always room for something like you in
China and just give you one example of
I've been helping to bring a
class from Stanford China energy class
it's taught every two years of the
teacher actually brings the entire class
to China for their spring break we just
had him in China last month but the
class of last time two years ago
included a woman who was you know
interested in renewable energy in China
and after she graduated one of the
places we visited on the two-week tour
was a gold wind which is now one of the
largest wind energy manufacturers in
China she called them up and they said
come and work with us in Xinjiang
province way out western China near
Tibet so she went out there for several
years and and it was one of their
leading lights now she's working for a
consulting firm on wind in in Beijing so
I just wanted to say that can I just
mention one more trend I think on the
sub-national level to watch that I
forgot to mention and and that is as you
probably all know China is now developed
and announced today climate carbon
intensity target between now and 2020
and that's going to be included in the
12th five-year plan that will be
approved next year in the thirteenth
five-year plan again it'll be allocated
to the provinces been put in that job
target responsibility system but we're
already seeing a tremendous interest on
the part of provinces and cities to
develop what's called low-carbon
development zones or low carbon
development plans it's like in China
years ago what sparked the development
of the private sector a market-based
economy was special economic zones where
they had certain tax breaks just you
know for private enterprises but but
anyway so we've been received with
requests from different provinces from
from different cities to help them
develop low carbon development plans and
what I like about this is that it's it
integrates efficiency it integrates
renewables also transportation city
planning and on all the elements of
low-carbon development so keep that
people watch on that
and we'll do that absolutely it's
interesting question how does a social
entrepreneur in this sector succeed from
the Indian context we do have plenty of
angel investors who are trying to offer
a low-cost finance in terms of such
activities and the kind of solution
which I am piloting back home is how to
make a financial institutions bite the
bullet in terms of trying to really
invest in octuple activities at the
bottom of pyramid on energy and their
one root which I could find at a very
small level is to use your philanthropic
budget to give low cost debt and see how
the entire entrepreneur sector is able
to function is it able to absorb that
debt can it go from proof of concept to
a demonstration plot and then can you
use that entire demonstration piece to
be able to then attract more funding I
mean I mean you help go through the
grant approach towards the load was that
to be able to create some balance sheet
and some sales quotient to be able to
then say find we are now ready for
regular funding that helps sometimes
okay it is 530 on a friday afternoon
that it's absolutely gorgeous outside
and and I have to compliment each and
every gotta complement each and every
one and you're still here this is
astounding first of all I want to thank
this distinguished panel join